[Music]
thank
you good evening everyone how you guys
feeling tonight you still have energy
yes thank you for that introduction
thank you love tomorrow for inviting me
to share some thoughts with you guys
today my name is Jason Silva my
background is is as a television
presenter and filmmaker I hosted a show
called brain games on the National
Geographic Channel for many years that
show was all about the ways in which the
brain perceives reality but also all
about the ways in which the brain often
misperceives reality we have a lot of
cognitive loopholes and we make a lot of
cognitive errors and we don't often see
the world as it is but we see it through
a prism of stereotypes and expectations
and biases and I'd like you to keep that
metaphor in mind as I share with you
some thoughts about the accelerating
future that is increasingly coming into
existence I call the future
cyberdelic it's a kind of intersection
between
cybernetics right and psychedelics
increasingly the
imagination it seems is summoning its
own
literalization but before we get there
where does this begin for me this Begins
for me with a passion for human
creativity this Begins for me with a
passion for human
imagination and this has turned into a
passion for technology because I believe
that at its best technology literalizes
human
imagination technology is the
concretization of human creativity in
the world technology is the human mind
turned inside out the cognitive
philosophers David Chalmers and Andy
Clark in their seminal essay the
extended mind thesis they describe
technology as a scaffolding of the mind
that extends our thoughts our reach and
our
vision and it has always been so if you
go back a 100,000 years to the savanas
of Africa when early hominids first
picked up a stick from the ground and
used that stick to reach a fruit that
was hanging off a high tree branch we've
been using our tools we've been using
our sticks we've been using our
instruments to extend our reach to
overcome our boundaries and our
limitations to transcend our limits
right as Marshall mclen the famous Phil
philosopher said we build the tools but
then the tools build us we've been in a
co-evolution of humans and Technology
since the dawn of humanity that has been
accelerating now fast forward to the
present day we live in an age of
acceleration we live in an age of
disruption we live in an age of digital
transformation increasingly there's a
kind of vertigo as these exponential
Technologies start upending reality
transforming the world whether it's
artificial intelligence or biotechnology
and genetics we're increasingly
slingshotting into the future but the
question is why right technology has
always changed the world the printing
press the origin of language the wheel
we've always disrupted and redefined
ourselves and redefined our boundaries
and transcended our maps of possibility
but these changes used to happen over
many generations and now they're
happening within our own lifespans and
again the question is why and this has
to do with something called exponential
Technologies digital transformation the
tools the technologies that are upending
the world advance and progress at
exponential rates but human beings we
think about change linearly we have
linear intuitions and linear biases in
an exponential world so what's the
difference between linear and
exponential change the example Ray Kurtz
uses takes 30 steps if you take 30
linear steps over time you get to 30 if
you take 30 exponential steps over time
you get to a billion 30 exponential
steps gets you to a billion 30 linear
steps gets you to 30 so if you think
linearly your future blind exponential
progress is the reason the smartphone in
your pocket today today is a million
times cheaper a million times smaller
and a thousand times more powerful than
a supercomputer that was half a building
in size 40 years ago so the tools to
change the world the supercomputers of
yesterday that only the rich and
privileged could access are now in
everybody's hands a young kid in Africa
with a smartphone has better
Communications technology than a head of
state had 25 years ago in the next 25
years these technologies will shrink to
the size of blood cells we'll
increasingly be able to turn biology
into an information technology and our
ability to create medical interventions
that reverse engineer US from inside out
whether it's curing cancer or radically
extending the human lifespan are also
advancing exponentially our ability to
program atoms using nanotechnology
increasingly turns matter into a
programmable medium and so we're leaning
into a world shaped by human imagination
as dve David deuts wrote in the
beginning of infinity if you look at the
Topography of a modern city like
Manhattan that's a topography that is
shaped more by mind Consciousness
intentionality and human will than by
geology we already know the unintended
consequences of how we're impacting the
planet but there are all sorts of ways
in which US transcending geology means
that we have within us the capacity to
not just address the grand challenges of
humanity but create a world beyond our
imagination and awaken ourselves to all
of our cyberdelic dreams so I'd like to
show you first a quick video called the
future of us because it is my aim to use
media and storytelling to light a fire
under people's ass and get them thinking
differently please show the first video
so let's talk about the future of us
what is that even meet the future of us
it's a look at what comes next it's a
look at what might be cuz today
exponentially emerging Technologies are
transforming what's possible they are
helping us overcome transcend even
biological limitations the very rules of
what it is to be human are up for grabs
we're rewriting the software of life
with
biotechnology we're turning matter into
a programmable medium with
nanotechnology we're creating sentient
Minds with artificial intelligence that
are not bound by the limitations of
biology these three overlapping
revolutions GNR genetics nanotechnology
and Robotics together will be leveraged
to lead us towards a black hole like
impossible to Fathom Singularity it's
like staring into the Sun a moment of
arousing symphonic climax when all of
Mind leverage the network together
transcends its biological Origins and we
become something more people worry about
the AIS and the them well as kwell says
that's going to be us the future of us
is ours to dream
up now there is a sense that we're
moving in such acceleration that we're
moving so fast into the future that
things might go off the rails Edward O
Wilson he has a famous line he says we
have Paleolithic brains medieval laws
and Godlike technology and so the
question BEC becomes how do we summon
the necessary wisdom to deploy these
tools in a way that addresses the grand
challenges of humanity and gives us a
new North Star One shaped by human
imagination and our capacity to dream
reality into existence one of the most
exciting things about artificial
intelligence I think is to create new
ways of paint ing our inner life of
exteriorizing our imagination those
ineffable inner universes inside of us
that we struggle to communicate with
language now I've been doing this with
AI to try to create a form of liquid
imagination to paint my dreams on the
screen and inspire people to think
differently about these emerging
Technologies and about the future of
human creativity and human
self-expression and that's what this
last video is about as it grow grapples
with the famous Philip K dick question
and novel do Android's Dream of Electric
Sheep let us ask this question and think
about our future as we watch this next
video thank You Do Androids Dream of
Electric Sheep I've always loved the
title of that story by Philip K dick and
it feels ever more preent today do
Android's Dream of Electric Sheep we ask
oursel this question as we increasingly
grapple with a world of synthetic
intelligence where more and more of our
interactions are happening with
algorithms that seem to exhibit some of
the qualities of awareness some of the
qualities of sentience it's the dawn of
artificial intelligence it's the dawn of
a kind of intelligence explosion and as
we grapple with the philosophical issues
raised by this encounter with a new kind
of mysterium tremendum a new kind of
synthetic mysterium tremendum we are
having to ask deep questions about what
it means to have a psyche what it means
to have an inner world what it means to
have theory of mind what it means to
have an inner psychology and so of
course Philip K dick was ahead of his
time when he asked the question to
Android's Dream of Electric Sheep you
know when Eric Davis wrote about the
spiritual cyborg in his book technosis
he wrestled with this very same thing we
are the spiritual cyborg we are the
thing that is a hybrid of biological and
non-biological intelligence we create
second skins and scaffoldings we are
increasingly merging with our tools and
Technologies but now we are spawning a
technology that talks back now we are
spawning a kind of artificial personhood
and we're interacting and engaging in a
feedback loop with that artificial
personhood and so again we should ask
this question we should get into a
platonic conversation about what this
means and where we're heading as we
increasingly want
do Android's Dream of Electric Sheep do
Android's Dream of Electric
Sheep thank you so much I hope that
leaves a lot to think about cheers guys
good
night